Good morning John, it is October third it is Wednesday October third.
so I have a song
and this has nothing to do with the yeti
uh but it's dedicated to the yeti
because it's her birthday
you would never do this to the yeti
this song is about a woman scorned
♩Baby close your eyes and hear the words I say♩
♩Oh I realize That you're in a lot of pain and I apologize♩
♩I never wanted it this way oh Please...don't cry♩
...don't cry..
♩baby i sold your dog on ebay♩
♩ We both knew that we had bills to pay ♩
♩ it was either him or my playstation 2, which doesn't even eat food and will never ever pee on the duvet ♩
One day I came home and that dog had escaped he forsook his bone , and instead he ate everything I own
♩ from the couch to the drapes I called you on the phone and said "I'm selling him on Ebay" ♩
♩ we both know that we've got bills to pay ♩
♩ He peed on season 2 of Deep Space 9 That's crossing the line I'm listing the auction today ♩
♩ I put him in a box with some Styrofoam peanuts a bag of kibble and a couple of milk bones ♩
♩  the guy online paid for overnight shipping so the very next day he was in Buffalo  ♩
♩ Oh, please don't cry, Oh, please don't cry, Baby, please don't cry, Goddammit, stop crying. ♩
♩ He is an ugly dog like a ball of walking fuzz and he poops constantly more than any other dog does♩
♩but we won't have to worry about him anymore because babe listen to me ♩
♩ Yeah, I sold him on eBay we both knew that we've got bills to pay ♩
♩I got a hundred fifty dollars for that mutt that peed all over my floor and I know there'll be hell to pay♩
♩ Yeah we had bills to pay so I sold her dog on eBay I told her you have got to understand it ♩
♩ yeah, he could sit but he absolutely couldn't stay, yeah, he could sit but he absolutely couldn't stay ♩
okay that was a long song so i have to go
John tomorrow when I see you talk about the happy dance project